Good day.
This is a Slow Mo Guys
video involving Pyrex
Yeah , we got a couple of sizes here.
I noticed that on the warning label.
Yeah.
It says, "Avoid sudden
temperature changes.
Not for use on a stove-top."
So this is Slow Mo Guys, you
know that we like to ignore
all warning labels and do
exactly what it says not to do.
We just treat them like
an instruction manual
on how to destroy itself.
Yeah, what would make a
good Slow Mo Guys video?
Ah, don't do that, excellent.
Apparently, I read that Pyrex in the US
is different in that it's slightly crapper
than European Pyrex.
It's a lot crapper.
Yeah.
'Cause it's made of something
called soda-lime glass.
Yeah, and not borosilicate.
Borosilicate, which is what's the Europe.
For this video, which
will hopefully be glass
cracking and splitting everywhere,
we need a much higher
frame rate than usual.
So we've brought in the
big guns, the 25 11.
Shoots way faster.
I'll start filming at
28,000 frames a second,
that's 7-20 P.
And you know it's doing a lot of work
because it's loud as heck.
Looks a bit hot.
That's an understatement,
it's 38 degrees out here.
I'm in a blue rubber and flame-proof suit.
It's like I'm in a greenhouse.
That's what happens in June in Texas.
Oh, it's disgusting.
Is it not July?
It's July.
Oh, it's July.
Yeah.
All right.
So, what we're gonna do
is get this blow-torch,
and act like it's a
stove-top, like a gas stove.
Heat up the Pyrex, get
some ice-cold water.
And just dip-dip, put
a little bit in there,
and hopefully it'll just
explode in my hands.
A little dip-dip pow.
Dip-dip pssht.
And we'll fil it on this bad boy.
Lads and ladies, do not try this at home.
You ready?
Yeah.
So tell me when I'm in frame and that.
Is where I'm gonna be?
That's perfect there, but we can readjust
when you're absolutely ready.
Okay.
I'm absolutely ready.
Okay, let me get final foc'.
Okay, go for it.
Jesus.
You did it.
Flipping heck.
Oh.
God.
Pretty good.
That's insane.
Yeah.
What frame rate's this at?
28 thou'.
28 thou'?
That's the starting point is it?
Oh, look how fast that is.
Flip, and that's 28
thousand frames a second.
It just went straight round, didn't it?
There was no messing around.
That is madness.
I like how I'm holding it,
and then I'm suddenly holding nothing,
so my hand just goes, like, whoop.
That's insane.
It does actually explode
itself, doesn't it?
That is cool.
Jesus.
To stop the glass going
everywhere in the garden
I decided to put a tarpaulin down.
Didn't work.
The glass was so hot that it just melted
straight thorough and went
onto the grass anyway.
Look at it.
Look at all these holes.
I bet the glass didn't
even notice the tarp.
No.
It just landed on the grass
and thought, "Oh, what was that?"
Completely pointless.
That was great.
We do need to go faster, so
I'm gonna lower the res'.
We'll go way standard def' with it.
That'll give us 120, 000 fps.
Aw.
Good?
Meaty.
Okay, go.
Oh, that was different completely.
Was it.
Look.
Oh, wow.
Look how slow the water's falling.
There's nothing's happening.
Nothing's happening.
Well, what is happening is
the Pyrex is going, "Oh, God"
Oh no, God, it's so fast.
Flip.
It's rapid.
That is immensely cool.
As you can see, I've
sacrificed my lab-coat
to cool the camera down.
Oh, that's good of you.
It's rather hot, rather hot out.
I noticed in the first
clip that all of this
shattered pretty smoothly, all the lines,
but the handle turned almost into dust.
So what I wanna do is go
as fast as we can,
really, sort of 170,000,
and acceptable resolution,
on just this bit so we can
hopefully see that happen,
super-duper extreme-o bonanza fast.
Any more adjectives, or?
Floopin'
171,000 and a half frames per second.
Pretty mental.
That's disgusting.
Tell me if I'm out of frame again.
Oh shit.
What happened?
It just went.
Without you even doing it?
Didn't even touch it.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Were you framed up?
Yeah.
Who needs water?
That is ridiculous.
Wonder if just the air cooling it down
was enough to shock it.
That much?
Bugger me.
What happened to the handle, though?
Did the handle go?
Oh, the handle didn't even go.
Didn't it?
No.
Okay, so now we're using the second one
that partially smashed.
And just focusing on the handle.
And this is being filmed at
343,000 frames per second.
That is insane.
That is absolute madness.
That's a dank film rate.
This is over 13,000 times slower
than you can see with your own face.
Did it go?
I think it did, you know.
It's still really hot,
but look at the amount of detail,
the amount of cracks that're in that.
It's just completely,
you can't even see, can you?
What's amazing as well is the fact that
it was attached to the rest of this.
I just heated up this bit,
and only this part cracked.
Yeah.
Only this part went,
"No, I've had enough".
The rest of this
was just like, "Yeah, I'm
not involved in this."
I'm cool enough.
I'm cool enough, I'm fine.
Okay, how's this for a mental stat?
The camera recorded for 5.1 seconds.
Yep.
And generated 19 and a
half hours of footage.
I'm gonna be sick.
That's disgraceful.
Almost a day of footage.
That's vile.
Do you think we should just stick it,
like, put it on the second
channel as a whole video?
Just the entire 19 hours?
Would, what, and just put
nothing in the description?
How many people do you think
would actually watch it
to the point of, like,
where it does it?
Just searching through
19 hours of footage.
The break would be around
10 hours in, probably.
It's so hard to mentally get
your head around how fast
that glass is moving.
That, I think we should
do a comparison video,
of human reaction times.
So at the exact same frame rate,
I'm just gonna drop a
little water in your eyeball
and we'll be able to tell how
quickly you react to that,
compared to the video we just
shot of the handle breaking.
Yeah?
That's a great idea.
I mean, it's just gonna be
like looking at a picture.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna go like this.
I'm gonna go three two one.
Yeah.
Okay?
Don't move your hand away.
Yeah.
All right, ready?
Three two one.
Oh, that was it.
Oh, God, right in the eye.
That was great.
Oh God.
Direct hit on my eyeball.
I think that'll look really cool.
Well, that was immense.
I'm always blown away
every time we film it.
The speed that glass cracks.
Yeah.
Phenomenally fast.
Crazy, we couldn't do
it without this camera,
that's for sure.
Couldn't do it on the old Flex.
What's the science behind
that, do you think?
It's called "thermal shock",
which is where a sudden
temperature fluctuation
in a material causes the stress.
So, on the glass, you got the heat
wants to expand the glass,
and the sudden cold want to contract it.
So you got opposites.
And the glass just sort
of goes, "Urgh, tcha".
Just gives up.
Yeah, that's it.
Bad at commitment, the old glass.
It's just like, "I can't
handle it, I'm out."
"I'm done"
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
That's the fastest we've
ever filmed, so far.
I'm sure one day we'll exceed it.
Feel fee to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe, subscribe
to our second channel.
We've got a lot of behind the
scenes stuff on there now.
There's actually some good viewing.
And buy some merch if you want.
Sweaty T-shirts.
Sweaty T-shirts, we sell
ones without sweat on them.
Unless you want the sweat.
Unless you want Dan's sweat one.
I wanna go faster.
It can't be done.
One day.
No.
Do you ever stop to think that,
yeah, you can, but, should you?